Texas lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
Texas Rangers have been helping out down
here big big instance if like five
hundred Rangers came down to try to
disperse a caravan I know recently Dan
but well you could feel the frustration
on the Border Patrol there they are
incredible people but they are that mean
they're they're not going to do they're
livid I don't want to say they're
overwhelmed because they can handle
they're amazing but they can hint their
everything they can handle their
handling think about this Laura and by
the way welcome to Texas welcome to the
border all those people in the
background are coming in they're coming
in the legal way legal way yeah and so
let's look at Texas in El Paso we're a
free handing in El Paso sector about
nine hundred and thirty people a day
we're going to approach a million people
apprehended this year plus on the border
from California to Brownsville in Texas
and we think I was talking to law
enforcement do we get one out of every
three or four yeah it was just saying
six thousand they think in this sector
alone yes yeah they're calm got away
yeah so and there's probably more than
six thousand so the real number is much
bigger than a million coming in this
that's that's why I've said to you that
we have close to 10% of our population
now is here illegally you know there was
a poll recently that 152 million people
in the world want to come to America and
forty million of those live in Central
America and they're coming
last month law the big chant out came to
Del Rio at this sector twelve years ago
for the first time worked in the bushes
at night with the Border Patrol and our
local sheriffs and DPS and at that time
there were mostly single males crossing
last month we had thirty thousand single
males we caught but we had 63 thousand
families and that's what's happening and
and as we've said on your show before
the drug cartels use these people to to
distract and take up the time of the
Border Patrol and they run all the drugs
and everyone else up the middle the
politicians in Washington give me a
couple of ideas solutions well first of
all talk about politicians I saw you had
one of the Castro brothers on earlier I
could hear now they have as tape they
wouldn't come on so so think about this
we have Republicans and Democrats in
Texas the Republicans come down here and
see this the Democrats come here here
and ignore it and that's what they're
doing in Washington so what does
Washington have to do number one we have
to change the asylum laws
number two they have to give Trump his
money so that we can have fencing which
is higher this is more here where we
have a border crossing but in the areas
of no-man's land the fence is much
higher much tougher to climb so you have
to have the fencing and you have to give
these Border Patrol more assistance and
by the way to the Democrats get off
their back
you know that story you were telling
earlier about that that young battle who
drowned and here we had an agent in the
middle of the night putting his and you
you were on the river today you saw that
raging river but life that's how you the
21 days you've got to be able to hold
people longer than 21 days we have one
federal judge look in the camera thing
one federal judge dolly G or G whatever
it is that one judge is responsible for
much of this crisis to people dying
children being being temporarily
sometimes because someone's down the
river another one's up the river
separated the looking in the eyes of the
children today was a heartbreak
it is a hyzer as a mother and as it's a
heartbreak for the children and I also
have heartbreak for the American people
and the kids in public schools and
overcrowding I mean when it's a
heartbreak to see this happening that
they're being used that's why you know
when I was on your show a few weeks ago
I said that the Democrats I think are in
charge of modern-day slavery today all
these I know and I bet you saw this well
I bet you saw this there were adults
with children you could tell the
children weren't really their children
there was a particular was you knew your
sex trafficking in it
Democrats have got to realize this is a
national crisis it's not manufactured I
mean we're being overrun Laura but thank
you for continuing our story and telling
the truth well I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna stop and Texas is on the front
line we're the frontline state dan thank
you so much